blog mans numero 11 in questi ultimi
giorni ho fatto un sacco di cose ho
montato alberi infatto presepi costruito
leggo qualsiasi cosa potessi fare per
tenermi occupato ed è da un pò di giorni
che vorrei in realtà vivere una mia
giornata tipo senza dover per forza far
uscire
non so i razzi al giudice la mia
giornata tipo è che non risponde al
telefono
volevo vivere una giornata assolutamente
normale ma mi è venuta un'idea per
renderla un minimo interessante anche
divertente
esiste un sacco di format su youtube
ultimamente che vanno vanno di moda
dalla smr il gameplay un sacco di cose
che io per esempio non ho mai provato
molto probabilmente non proverò mai
nella mia vita
ecco perché mi sono detto ma perché non
provi a trasformare ogni cosa che fai
durante la giornata in un format di
youtube partiamo con beauty routine che
venisse bega e la mattina come prima
cosa ci crediate o no mi lavo i denti
usi questa cosa a murata che vibra
costeggiamo spazzolino credeteci o no la
passing su tutti dai mancio guarda sarà
un bar a blair o come seconda cosa mi
faccio la barba e utilizzo questo cosa
che ho comprato su amazon
se volete vivamente il link 48 così
potete acquistarlo pure voi lo attacchi
qui a queste ventose sullo specchio e lo
leghi comodamente al collo e inizia a
crederci
questo è un rasoio della philips dopo
che ho finito la prima passata col
rasoio utilizzo un altro rasoio ora devo
dire questo qui della philips vedete
dalla pelliccia
l'one blade tenore migliora solo io mai
creato fino ad oggi così come le ragazze
col trucco si fanno un contouring io me
lo faccio con la barba in modo da
togliermi con il 7 kg dalla faccia
naturalmente mi metto clinca anche per
l'acquisto di questo soccorso sarà chi
andremo a sistemare i teli che dico che
mi crescono sotto gli occhi i teli delle
occhiaie le fiamme fino a questo
contaminato i capelli al volo e per
lavarli utilizzo dello shampoo che
potevate credere di più delle volte
puliscono la vasca per eliminare i
residui di morte dal mio ultimo bagno e
vai vai a buttare bevilacqua sui capelli
così in maniera naturale
prendo dello shampoo che batte l'uscente
in questo movimento il circolatorio come
quando cerchi di montare gli albumi
non è che esco così poi lo sciacquone
assurda come cosa lo so sono pazzo e
rivoluzionari oggi pretendo canto la
canzone sacal h che fa così scala che la
canzone cha calata di parlare meglio i
capelli
ed è finito in moltissime mi chiedete
come faccio ad asciugare i capelli per
avere come ricci perfetti e la risposta
è una sola non li asciugo ha fatto
rimango così per ore t come la mia pelle
si sta sfaldando cioè io mi perdo pezzi
pelle mentre che me lo sento un po toc
toc per sole cose che cadono utilizzerò
la mia crema preferita devo fare la cosa
è la mamma di fermo se la mano la mia
creano preferita raffaele ruberto number
nine che è una specie di super banking è
pazzesca è veramente veramente buona
devo esser sincero ancora non è
disponibile in italia ma siccome conosco
raffaele sono riuscito a ottenerla e
danni giacche che ce l'ho ma la cosa
positiva è che arriverà in italia nelle
mie 19 che sono contentissimo per lui
viene per la mia beauty immaginatevi di
essere il vostro peggior nemico sia
facciate vedere in faccia basta per
stare lì capezza archi h giocato come se
le nostre mani appartenesse al 90
tradito è la vostra faccia al porco
traditore
lui dice permesso poiché si è permesso
passo agire
ho notato che facendo così cioè cambia
proprio il risultato e poi prendono al
numero 11 che come vedete è praticamente
distrutta finita di è per farvi capire
che io non vendo sogni ma solide realtà
e la utilizzo come coating di questo
primer adoro questi termini in inglese
del bio di calcio calcio voglio vedere i
tuoi commenti le persone che girano va
letta così chissà che faccia avere 30
anni beh ho già trent'anni credete o no
a botto sto morendo di fame e quindi è
arrivato il momento di fare un e mai
freccia niente spinaci dei sette giorni
fa un pezzo di formaggio pecorino e
parmigiano caffè ginseng dati che
continuano a comprare perché dimentico
di averli soia forse la cosa più
commestibile l'attak qua dentro delic
vide fine del mio ma vabbè fa la spesa
se voglio mangiare
importantissimo il che allora io devo
uscire per andare a fare la spesa e deve
optare per un look tra le varie cose che
ho quindi quello che faccio io è tata ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta fiorina un maglione
blu perfetto e lui andiamo ragazzi
questo è il mio look of the day scarpe
zara jeans maglione naturalmente zara
faccia zara tutto farà ragazzi sono
tornati al supermercato è arrivato il
momento del mio
all acquisti al supermercato allora
praticamente alla fine ho comprato
tutta roba che in tre minuti ma giusta
ho preso appreso le patatine le fragole
vestiti né ed usa lamma i mandorli
queste cose in gaza perché pesa culo una
run cirla ranjit e sicilia lì a dire ho
fame non avete voglia di mangiare
insieme a me ragazzi è venuto il momento
di mangiare normale mangiare così
compriamo tipo quanto focaccia
ho fatto l'errore che bale a quando il
miglior affare non era acceso ma mi
sento un mezzo correttivo mandorle
tostate proprio amore c'è una cena ma
cosa succede se faccio questo porterà
meglio nel piatto andiamo avanti con una
ciliegia sì una trappola e batteria di
mangiare o la bocca aperta e fa sentire
meglio potremo l'arancia arancia e
shampoo la fame fine eccoci qui da nomos
qua ragazzi salve a tutti
sta per partire una rubrica che tutti i
pacchi per nomos perché qui mi sono
arrivati un pochino di pensieri di kato
e quindi è tempo di unboxing unboxing
ripetilo 6 coraggio la scorsa volta si
spera sia stata molto brava
il mio dono della regia c'è scritto
netflix se questo di fragola
delle scale
ho capito perfettamente come funziona
questa cosa se recchia e allora ti
mandiamo in questo unboxing bellissima
che cos'è è una palla di natale spelar
chi lo scopriamo insieme
scopriamo includendo in questo formato
dvd di persone gargano cose ma dovrei
fare anch'io ma le cose se recuperano
mondo di porno di persone care le cose
altro presente che girerò a erba sì ma
in che senso
non lo so che vengo echi da presepe in
odio chi è oddio di michele non è pazzo
i narcos
no direi che è stato un signore unboxing
presenza di boksic consegnare signor
signore di un signore adesso glielo
vogliamo dire a tutti che cosa
desidereresti che sideri resti una porta
da femmina signori da notare forse
quello che alloggia il presepe più bello
di tutti anche se ci stiamo indagando su
instagram su chi sia lui un giovane eros
ramazzotti in una idea
ci auguriamo a casa e sono venuto da te
sono date sono venuto solo da te ho
fatto cinque ordini a piedi sta morendo
sono qui con il mio cane e del tempo di
recensione allora recensirò credo il mio
cane come vedete un cane fa rumore
vuole giocare non alla coda proprio gli
manca mai avuta cioè nato senza coda
compenso ha molta pelle
potete vedere moltissima pelle anche
morbida morbida al tatto piacevole
urlati qui risponde al nome di culto
come potete vedere gli piace essere al
centro dell'attenzione che è quel cane
linee chi è quel cane li bravo bravo
ho bisogno di molto su questo fratello
recensisco anche il mio fratello e
gianluigi e se fai così sembra che gli
tiene la faccia
bravo bravo e poi di vuole mordere è un
cane carino insomma dolce alla moda ma
anche perché non indossa niente è
completamente nudo quando non ve ne
siete accorti e impazzisce per questi
cosi
oddio oddio
inoltre siccome ho mangiato come se
fosse il protagonista di cast away che
avresti arrivato un momento di farmi uno
spuntino e qual è il miglior modo per
fare uno spuntino se non con il mach
bang un look punk come si chiama che
succede succede a enrico che così è
bello della diretta perché è sentito
rimando del video è il bello della
adesso abbiamo fatto una reaction a un
video oggi non era una reaction pazzesca
di a giorni ci stiamo a noi under pineto
ha deciso di fare un gameplay a cosa che
si fa quindi esattamente come mi muovo
aspern sa dove sono
immagino che questo da questo è un
tirannosauro no il tema era leopardi
cinque minuti di oggi
è natale 3.000 a salire perticolarmente
su unix 58 secondi ci sia proprio là di
qualche anno fa però da brave nel mio
natale 3000 abbiamo un bellissimo babbo
natale sopra a una bellissima mezzo
astronave no vedete qui l'infrazione
adesso che ne sappiamo un ufo per essere
colonizzata da grillo
ovviamente non hanno capito bene il
natale quindi vengono nel 3000 ianieri e
joni concettuale giorno dice questo ciò
segnala radicato non va mai giudicato
ognuno volere la sua espressione il suo
modo di agire è quello che vede quello
là dentro se no al punto da genovese un
peccato originale e io ho fatto il
bellissimo mal bellizzi albero con dove
poter essere privato e scusami a fare
quelle da nessuna parte
il mio invece è un bruco poi questo
albero un po concettuale e questo poi
acquista attivandolo con dentro la mela
è il ciclo continuo
serpente che striscia sopra equazioni
rafa posso dire anche la mia che ho
veramente o caduti in seguito appunto
per la donna luigi ma deve essere deve
essere raggiunti sia chiaro
[Musica]
vai in 2d proprio punto di mora possiamo
giorni questo è l'elogio ok
chiudiamo sfida contro ci vediamo una
droga alle 14
[Applauso]